joining us brand new Fox News
contributor former interim DNC
chairwoman Donna Brazile are gonna have
a lightening round with first of all you
should say welcome Donna welcome welcome
I've known you for years we have had a
very friendly I would say cordial
relationship we've met at a lot of
debates we've met a lot of conventions
we always have a good time we ask how
each other is doing and we never agree
on much do we
no but that's not the point the point is
is that it's a great honor to be back on
your show and I'm looking forward to
these conversations okay I'm not running
first of all I'm not gonna use my
microphone to run for anything I'm
making new announcements tonight but I'm
glad to see you tonight on st. Joseph's
Day so by the way just for being on this
show you will get in trouble with some
Democrats we on Hannity show why did you
talk to him he's not a nice guy and then
you're gonna have to you know tell him
well he's that man you know Hannity
shine a couple of weeks ago you had me
on the show we talked about my new book
I'm a co-author with for the I mean
three other women for color girls who
consider politics so you've had me on
the show before so thank you for having
me again well welcome to the Fox News
Channel and for those who say we don't
have varying opinions I could go down
the list and if I do I'll probably get
in trouble so I want to stay away from
trouble for once in my life all right
let's go through or play a lightning
round I'll just ask you to play along
Medicare for all is going to be three
point three trillion dollars for every
year for ten years and people like
Kamala Harris a people would have no
choice at private health care do you
agree with that we're in the beginning
of a very extensive conversation and
it's not about radicalism it's about
making sure that Americans can this is
the lightning round I'm asking Donna
Brazile two minutes I gotta go through
the listing so many errors but Medicare
there's a little when you expand how
high all right Oh over fifty six percent
of the American people support some form
of
medicare-for-all medicare plus medicaid
you know except I mean people be allowed
to get private insurance if they want to
keep their private insurance and
maintain it as I would all right you
disagree with Kamala okay next question
no I don't disagree but I hope she can
explain exactly she's down on it every
American and ensure that we don't have
millions of Americans who cannot afford
their prescription drugs as well we got
to have a good we got to get the light
time to expend now a lot of your party
eight states and even in Congress want
late term abortions in one case you had
a woman in the Virginia House of
Delegates say that even up to the
birthing process dilation she supports a
woman right woman's right to have an
abortion isn't exactly true but let me
say there's Democrats both the
governor's Democrats believe that this
is a choice that women should have a ACN
we believe that woman's in the ninth
month of pregnancy right look we believe
that yes it should have the fool the
ninth month of pregnancy in the child
services I am NOT a doctor and I'm not
going to tell anyone what to do with his
or her body so I'm not this is not look
the Democratic Party also believe very
strongly so in 48 hours and she decides
to have an abortion you don't think we
have a duty and responsibility on you I
believe that is a woman I would like to
have the full range of reproductive
health services now that's the answer I
believe I believe that this is a
decision that I should I should have in
consultation with my doctor and other
medical professionals that usually I
have taken do you support the new green
deals goal of getting rid of all oil and
gas in ten years I believe that HR x HR
109 should be should be debated
I believe it's going to go before at
least four or five committees we need to
do something with about climate our
climate changes we get rid of oil and
gas I believe that we need to find
cleaner sources cleaner resources and
yes I do now Shawn we need to you agree
this that we should face I can't do this
in 30 seconds this is these are very
important issues I mean that night it
says in the green hair it says
everything's gonna be free and that no
ten years in ten years we're gonna get
rid of oil gas ten years in ten years
they're going to get rid of oil gas the
combustion engine and hopefully soon
thereafter airplanes and cows it's black
and white and I'm asking do you support
that that's not be is not PolitiFact
even have they've gone after many people
who said these these things about the
cop I believe that they are credible
source and looking at this this is a
piece of legislation HR 109 go look for
go look at it yourself and stop trying
to exploit the fact that they're they're
talking about you made me read the darn
thing after I was on this show last time
and I'm like that's nothing in this I
said they won't let me ask you the next
question next question all right do you
think that it's a good idea to secure
our southern borders with with walls I
believe we need to use multiple methods
to secure support in the North or the
South land no I do not believe that the
president plant will work do you believe
we should continue to have ice and fund
ice and other law enforcement officers I
don't I don't I believe we need
comprehensive immigration reform I'm not
do I believe that we need to reform ice
I don't like the job that they're doing
now so I have not taken a personal
position
but yes I do understand that there are
other members of the Democratic Party
and by the way I don't speak all
Democrats only speak for Donna do you
want to get rid of know you're the
former head of the DNC do you want the
voting age or just do you want the
voting age lowered to 16 do you want the
Electoral College removed and do you
want more Supreme Court justices added
to the nine do I what I like to see the
the voting age Lord as several countries
include and I believe a Brazil a country
named after my family
Austria Brussels other countries yes and
Prince George is not Princeton highs
field Maryland as well as Takoma Park
they're experimenting with this we need
to experiment with more ways to engage
young people and get them more involved
in our democratic process okay do you
think there's been there's been I
believe for four times since 1860 when
the electoral college as you were know
the winner of the popular vote is the
winner of the popular vote has has lost
the electoral college I'm actually
reading a great book about this Sean so
we'll have enough all right I'm excited
about it
alright is there anything that you hear
of the current crop of 2020 candidates
where you say wow they're going to
promise a guaranteed salary they're
going to promise you know family leave
medical leave pre-k education college
education guaranteed guaranteed healthy
food guaranteed retirement guaranteed
health care you know is there anything
that I've also renewed 94 trillion
dollars in 10 years do you think that's
something that's at first of all I think
that's fuzzy math and no the textbook
definition of socialism no these are
policy Bo the the palace these are
policy ideas that Democrats are offering
many Democratic candidates are offering
to the voters the voters will ultimately
decide what are these policy
prescriptions they believe in and what
candidates they believe didn't carry
their agenda this is why we have
conversations and debates and Shawn if
you're not interested in listening to
the Democratic candidates then look
somewhere else
but these are
trust me these here's my idea I want to
also tell you what I disagree with you I
have known Adam Schiff for a long time
and you mentioned Adam Schiff he is a
very decent honorable person I'm always
gonna come on your show yes home - come
on
for the I'm offering him four hours and
I have everything documented I'm ready
to have that I think you can you can
look I'm not your Booker and I don't
know who will return your call in his
office but I can tell you it's not gonna
give you a tan so the last one it's
election day and he's all right God last
question is this Barack Obama was
president for eight years yes sir
putting aside the one hundred and fifty
billion dollar idiotic Iranian deal this
is what the economy was after eight
years thirteen million more Americans on
food stamps
eight million warm poverty lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s
we also have the worst recovery since
the 40s after his eight years the lowest
homeownership rate in 51 years the only
president in history that never reached
3% GDP in any of his years as president
he accumulated more debt than all 43
presidents before him combined
he hasn't gets rid of regulations you
know President Trump gets in office
we're now energy independent for the
first time in 70 years were a net
exporter of energy we now have created
six million new jobs over a million
fewer people on food stamps and in
poverty the lowest unemployment rate
ever for African Americans Hispanic
Americans Asian Americans women in the
workplace and youth unemployment tell me
why couldn't obey get done in eight
years what Trump got done in - well
first of all Trump could not have gotten
anything done had Obama not begin to
begin to put in the hard work and the
muscle and all of the energy to get this
economy back on his feet after the Great
Recession of 2008 I do believe that the
the legacy of President Obama will be
one of helping to sustain this economy
helping to rebuild the the economic
engine of our country
so well wimple why did he fail why did
it take eight years and we have 13
million more Americans on food stamps 8
million more in poverty you know what to
do you forget what Stacey Abrams said
let me repeat it I don't want this
president to fail I just want him to
tell the truth but i'ma tell you what
the last president wanted was tweet less
I hope he's watching I thought this
president roll up his sleeve and get to
work that's what I do what President
Obama did and that's the capital
it hasn't it Trump's to do he should
always be in Fargo Japan make and making
sure that every American get a head
start and a healthy start in life oh
that's what we all want
I'll take Trump's record over Obama's
failed record any day but anyway welcome
to the Fox News Channel I'll to have you
good record and I hope President Trump
continued to follow
I say Monday you ought to fill in on my
show and do you host the show Oh Shawn
can you imagine if I can be Shawn like
30 30 minutes a night come on baby
it's an hour show you can handle it hey
by the way thank you it's a great honor
I know we're not gonna always agree but
you know what the fact that you allowed
me on to give you my views in my two
cents I appreciate it and thank you
all right Donna Brazile thank you for
being with us